multiplica y expresa como una expresión
racional simplificada bueno cuando
queremos multiplicar expresiones
racionales hay que hacer lo mismo que
cuando multiplicamos fracciones hay que
multiplicar ambos numeradores y hay que
multiplicar ambos denominadores vamos a
hacer eso déjame ponerle que esto es
igual a entonces multiplicamos hay que
multiplicar todo este por todo este pero
como en la multiplicación no importa el
orden de los factores podemos
reacomodarlos convenientemente para
obtener pues para obtener algo más fácil
de multiplicar por ejemplo aquí nos
conviene primero multiplicar los
coeficientes para hacer 3 por 14 déjame
tomar aquí el 3 en este color verde y el
14 también 3 por 14 es 42 42 y ahora
vamos con el resto de las letras voy a
ir en orden alfabético tenemos aquí a
cuadrada a cuadrada que la voy a poner
aquí como a cuadrada tenemos b
ve que la voy a poner en color rosa
tenemos ve y finalmente tenemos x que le
toca el color azul muy bien entonces a
cuadrada de x eso sería el numerador y
tenemos que dividir entre el producto de
los denominadores otra vez déjame
empezar con los coeficientes 2 por 18 es
36 36 y ahora vamos con las letras aquí
tenemos a entonces aquí quedaría a aquí
tenemos un ave que está en color rosa
aquí hay un ave entonces aquí quedaría
como ve y finalmente tenemos esta x aquí
está la equis que la ponemos por acá muy
bien ahora estoy aquí ya es la
multiplicación sin embargo debemos
debemos simplificar la debemos cancelar
los términos comunes del numerador y del
denominador vamos a hacer eso paso a
paso
a ver si observamos 42 y 36 ambos
comparten un factor 6 vamos a
simplificar lo dividimos entre 6 el
numerador y nos queda 7 entre 6
y nos queda 6 entonces aquí nos quedaría
dividido entre 6 vamos con el resto de
las letras aquí tenemos a cuadrada y
abajo tenemos a entonces podemos
cancelar una arriba y abajo y arriba
simplemente nos quedaría a entonces aquí
se cancelan nada y aquí otra simplemente
lo que estoy haciendo es dividir entre a
en el numerador y en el denominador y
por lo tanto no se altera la expresión
bueno entonces acá aquí abajo nos
quedaría x 1 y arriba nos quedaría por a
7 por a vamos con las b esta vez se
cancela con esta vez entonces aquí nos
queda 1 y aquí también 1 aquí entonces
no ponemos nada y finalmente si vamos
ahora con x
aquí está x se me olvidó ponerle al
cuadrado verdad aquí está x elevado al
cuadrado entonces sería x al cuadrado
qué bueno que no se me escapó entonces
sería x al cuadrado dividido entre x
simplemente es x aquí nos queda x y
abajo queda
muy bien entonces déjame reescribir esto
para que se vea más bonito esto sería
igual a 7
x
x / la x la voy a poner así dividido en
36 muy bien entonces ésta sería la
simplificación sin embargo me gustaría
decir algo importante aquí estamos
suponiendo que ni a ni b ni x son 0 para
poder cancelar las es decir para que
realmente esta expresión sea equivalente
a esta expresión de acá o bien esta
expresión con la que empezamos debemos
de ser cuidadosos que a b y equis son
distintos de 0 porque observa en esta
expresión a podría ser 0 o x podría ser
0 no hay nada que lo impida pero de este
lado si a x son iguales a 0 entonces
estaríamos dividiendo entre 0 y la
expresión estaría indefinida entonces
debemos cuidar eso lo que tenemos que
cuidar es que el dominio si se preserva
verdad y como aquí ya no tenemos la
información del dominio en la expresión
tenemos que escribirlo aparte entonces
déjame ponerlo por acá el dominio
el dominio
para esta expresión es todos los reales
todos
los reales los números reales le voy a
poner los números
reales
para ave y x
para
de perdón a v y x excepto excepto
o equis o equis igual a cero muy bien
otra vez la explicación es la siguiente
para que esta expresión sea realmente
equivalente a ésta debemos de poder
meter los mismos números entonces eso lo
cuidamos restringiendo el dominio aquí
no podemos meter ni a ni b ni equis
igual a cero entonces esa misma
restricción se la ponemos a esta
expresión de acá y bueno esto a lo mejor
no sea algo que que se vea en clase
porque es algo muy específico pero sí es
importante sale cuando simplificamos
expresiones racionales hay que cuidar
que en los denominadores no tengamos
cero y bueno ya al realizar la
simplificación entonces salvo ese esa
cosa ese detalle con el cual debemos de
tener cuidado obtenemos expresiones
equivalentes